well
you know let's let's work our way up
from
the troublesome to the fantastic
[Music]
well you know what having now completed
my uh go through
of um christopher eccleston's run series
one of the revised
doctor who you know all of the ninth
doctors
televised episodes i think it's worth
revisiting
my ranking of these stories because it's
been a long time since i did that and
how
now having done a re-watch of them this
uh this list is a little bit different
than it had been previously
so i i didn't i didn't actually go back
and check to see how many of these
moved around shifted places but i know a
few of them are and i'm also going to be
doing them the same way that i actually
did the episodes which means that i am
breaking up
bad wolf and the parting of the ways but
i am keeping
uh the empty child in the doctor dances
in one as one story don't think that
makes any sense add tough it's my list
so uh this is actually going to be a
ranking of 11
uh episodes or stories or what have you
so
uh we'll just do the way i normally do
it start at the bottom work our way up
number 11 the long game
it's just got the fewest redeeming
features
at the end of the day basically it's got
simon pegg
and a couple of interesting ideas like
the like the concept of
you know this high pursuit of journalism
and that lying is is a
crime that it doesn't do anything with
and that's one of the things that can
really
frustrate me about doctor who when it
takes something that is an idea that
could totally carry its own episode
but it's like a side note in an episode
that's about something that's not nearly
as interesting that happens from time to
time and i feel like it does that here
um so that's that's frustrating and like
this is one of the few times that i feel
like eccleston didn't really get a
chance to shine i don't think he gives a
bad performance but he just
isn't given a heck of a lot to do
in this particular one adam is adam
mitchell is annoying like i said i mean
i like simon pegg but then ultimately
we're stuck with a mouth in the ceiling
as the main bad guy
just yeah skip it so number 10
and i know i'm gonna get grief for this
bad wolf
unlike the long game this has more
redeeming value although for me
it's basically all in the last 10
minutes because the first half hour is
eaten up with the
uh with the reality and game show
parodies and i'm i'm sorry guys look
i get that some people like them more i
get that they
work better for some people like i get
it
i hate them i'm not saying you have to
hate them but i hate them i didn't think
they were funny at the time i think
they're even less funny now
so that first 30 minutes being stuff
that i really don't want to watch
makes this a slog for me basically right
up until
it gets into the home stretch where it's
setting up the next episode which is why
i
i have to break it which is why when i
did the episode by episode reviews i
didn't right now here
i'm separating it from the parting of
the waves because if i lump them
together it really does just
end up in this weird middle place
because one of them i like one of them i
really don't so again i recognize bad
wolf is not devoid
of good features and the things that i
don't like other people
do like cool awesome i still hate it
sorry i do so moving up and away from
that number nine
the unquiet dead again this is mainly a
case of
not so much a ton of bad elements as it
is not
all that many great elements i mean the
best thing going on here is eccleston's
performance he gets some of his better
sort of alien moments
um like especially i love when uh
rose is saying you know you can't just
use dead bodies to house alien
spirits and the doctor's like why not
it's the ultimate recycling because he
doesn't have that
human attachment to the body of a
deceased person
so it makes sense that he's approaching
this from an angle that humans kind of
find distasteful but makes a heck of a
lot of sense because he doesn't have
that emotional attachment
so he gets a lot of good little moments
like that uh the performance of the guy
who plays charles dickens he's also
quite good um it's a little bit gimmicky
but it's probably one of the better
appearances of a famous historical
figure all things considered
i mean the overall story though is just
kind of
fine it's there it's yeah
it's fine it's very neat as an episode
it's not bad
it's not great so uh moving up a slot
from there that will take us to
number eight father's day
this is actually up i'm pretty sure from
where i had it
previously because i have been on the
record as really not liking father's day
and what i have come to acknowledge is
the things that i have never liked about
father's day i
still don't like about father's day the
primary one being the reapers
i think the literalization of the
paradox
through the reapers was completely
unnecessary and stupid and undermines it
i think
the emotional moments lose their impact
when you cut away to a
cgi monster outside the church going
i think i think they they actively
undermine the things that work
what i now have to acknowledge which was
something i
wasn't giving the episode it's due for
back when i was doing my
back when i did my last ranking of this
is that the stuff that
works works better than i was giving it
credit for the stuff that's bad is still
bad
but the stuff that is good is a lot
stronger than
i was giving it credit for previously
and that pretty much all surrounds pete
pete is a really great performance and
his interactions and his chemistry his
um performance chemistry with rose is
really terrific and the doctor has some
really nice nuanced moments as well and
rose does pretty well like
the the emotional core of this is really
good
the logistical way that it plays out
takes in my mind some major missteps and
it ends up
you know kind of landing here as a
result of that
so moving up from there number seven
rose uh again the things that are good
are great and top of the list here
eccleston
like he really he i fell in love with
his doctor
so soon into this like basically
as soon as as he shoes rose out of the
department store
and sort of pops back out and goes i'm
the doctor by the way what's your name
rose tyler nice to meet you rose run for
your life
like that oh that was the moment i was
like yes
i love this guy and he he's he's
terrific he is the
major hook into this um the the extended
bits with your rose sort of meeting the
guy who like has been tracking the
doctor
and and things like that and the and you
know the whole
use of the nesting and the autons is
fine it's functional but the highlight
is very much
the doctor himself and the other stuff
is just sort of there it's not dragging
it down but it's not elevating it up
all that much either so that brings us
to number
six aliens of london
at world war iii this is another highly
frustrating viewing because honestly
stuff that works is great
as much as i hate the farting both as a
thing in and of itself
yes i get it politicians are blow to gas
bags
as but as much as i hate the farting and
how much of it there is especially
at a few points in here i do think the
performances of the
people playing the slovene are actually
quite good and quite intimidating
um and they do a lot to bring that
menace into their performance
the baby face look of the actual
creatures doesn't
quite work um like i get what they were
going for but i don't think it comes
together
but at the same time harry jones is
great the doctor is great
rose is great it's got one of my
favorite moments in the entirety of
series one which is the doctor saying
just
information and you know rose and harry
jones just telling him things are going
narrows it down
narrows it down narrows it down i don't
but at the same time then again i don't
really
love the stuff with jackie and mickey i
don't think it added a lot and i
and those aren't characters that at
least at this point in the series i
really cared about
and what happens with them here didn't
build towards my
liking them later on in the show none of
that's based off what little they get to
do here
so again it's a mix of really good and
then
some not so good moments and then it's a
question of how does that balance where
does this thing land overall
this is where it is so that brings us
now safely into the upper half
of series one so we get to number five
boom town which is an episode that i
kind of always had a soft sport soft
spot for and i feel
very validated on having now re-watched
it because
honestly up until like the very tail end
because the conclusion
is kind of rushed but up until
like the last five eight minutes i think
it's really solid
i like the dynamic of the dr
rose jack and sort of mickey trying to
figure out how
this fits into his life um i i enjoy all
that i
love the interaction between the doctor
and the one remaining slovene i think
that is phenomenal the scene at the
restaurant especially
is great and it's it
the stuff the stuff that is good is
really good
i know that it takes a big hit from
people by its association with the
slitheen which i know a lot of people
don't like uh as villains and i i've
already expressed my own issues with
them
but there is a lot of this episode that
does
work even though it has a very rushed
and weird
uh conclusion to it so we get up to
number four
the end of the world i really do like
this episode and i i have an
awful lot of fun with it i love how
bonkers the show got
in its second episode in terms of look
okay fine we're not gonna really we're
not even gonna leave the orbit of the
earth
but we're still gonna make this really
alien we're gonna give you this little
tiny
blue guy we're gonna give you uh the
talking walking talking trees we're
gonna give you a giant face and a
jar we're gonna give you a flattened
slab of skin
that proclaims itself to be the last
living human being
like i love that that level of weirdness
all gets crammed into this one episode
i enjoy that quite a bit overall and um
i feel like the progression of the
threat is done pretty well
i like cassandra as a villain the doctor
gets great moments
rose has some really uh nice and sweet
moments in it as well
i just think this is uh this is this is
one of those good sort of i think of
them as the rip roaring episodes you
just sort of get in and you
yeah let's go it's it's it's a fun
little romp of an episode and
when those are done well i really enjoy
them and i really enjoy this
so that brings us up to number three
the parting of the ways sin yeah i mean
this this kind of shows you
what i mean by how much this would have
gotten dragged down
if i kept it paired with bad wolf
because i really like the parting of the
ways
a lot i love the i love the doll like
emperor
i love the booming authority and that
voice i love the build-up of the threat
of the daleks i
like you know jack do you know sort of
being annoyed with them is like i wish
i'd never met you i'm now trying to do
the right thing and it's going to get me
killed um and so i mean i like that
dynamic i i love i
love the hologram the moment of the
hologram telling rose i'm
sending you home because i'm going to
die have a good life
like that's a terrific moment um there
there are a couple of things that ding
it
um i think the the using the truck to
open up the tardis is a little bit of a
wonky moment and kind of goes on too
long
um i don't love i i neither love the
line
i think you need a doctor and i really
don't like the use of a kiss
for him to pull the tardis energy out of
rose
so i'm not a fan of that but then again
the doctor's actual goodbye when he
knows is regenerating
he explains it but it's simple it's to
the point it's not massively dragged out
i like that
quite a bit and i really do think that
this
episode ends eccleston's run on a very
strong note
on our way up to the top two and this
these should not be
surprises either one but number two
dalek
though the initial reintroduction of the
daleks
to darker who doctor who how do you
convince a whole new generation of fans
that this rolling trash bin with a
plunger on
one on the end of it is scary
this is how you take one only one
and you show how dangerous it is how
single-minded it is
how hateful it is and you show how
it brings the worst out of the doctor
and since
at this point you already know and like
the doctor
seeing that darkness be brought out of
him
also ups the whole thing because you're
going oh my god that
how horrible are these things that they
are making this guy that we love
act like that and i know when i did my
review of the episode i
said that i thought some of ecclestone's
anger performance was a little off i
should have been much more specific
when he's in the cage with the dalek i
think it's a little off but i do blame
part of that on the editing
i think the whole you know moment where
um
you know he says that he destroyed the
timelords and uh and the daleks
he said you know i watched it happen i
made it happen there's a really weird
cut where in the middle of that line
it cuts to the to the daleks perspective
and then cuts out of it it's a weird cut
that it makes the moment
really awkward and but there's like
another part of that that's
like a little off in terms of the
emotional transition but
when it's the doctor yelling at the
dalek over the
tv monitor and he and he he's yelling at
it and builds up to the
why don't you just die like that's
awesome so like when i did that nitpick
i mean i should have specified like how
specific
i was about that but seriously other
than that moment this is just a
phenomenal episode
top to bottom well constructed terrific
way to
to really show us why these things are
so dangerous
why they are the doctor's greatest enemy
using only one of them
it's great stuff not my favorite though
and if you've been
if you've been with this channel for any
amount of time at all should be no
surprise
number one episode of eccleston's run
number one episode of series one
has got to be the empty child
and the doctor dances i love
this so much like
everything absolutely everything about
this
i love to death ecclesia is giving a
phenomenal performance i love the gas
mask
look and like it is suitably creepy and
it's just otherworldly enough yet it's
yet the child is behaving in a way
that's like
something's off but i don't know what
because like a child would wear that
in this time period and the introduction
of jack
as a con man he's great rose has
terrific chemistry with basically
everybody in the room
and though the creepiness of it and
building to that gloriously triumphant
moment
of everybody liz lives and yes i know
the power of that has been diluted with
time
given how irritatingly common
that became the doctor saving everybody
should be the exception the idea that
it's the exception is the reason this
scene
works and later series of doctor who
really made it feel like
most of the time he saves everybody and
only sometimes he doesn't save somebody
and i you know that dilutes this moment
but when you look at this moment in
isolation
and you look at it in series one the way
eccleston sells it the way it's built up
to
his desperation at going up to take the
gas mask
off of this child and go let me have a
day like this give me this one
like you feel he needs this to go
right so bad and it is a gloriously
triumphant
moment i love it so much and the
entire two-parter building up to this
amazing climactic moment
is a terrific run in and of itself so it
nails the atmosphere
the setup the build up the payoff this
is the complete package i love
this two-parter and in my opinion it's
the best story
for the ninth doctor that's my now
newly redone list what are your thoughts
on it whatever they are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
you can do because there's buttons and
links you can go check out my patreon if
you feel like supporting me that way i'd
appreciate it but you know what
even if you don't not gonna hold it
against you there's other links to check
out
don't even wanna do that that's fine too
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council i just run the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
go
[Music]
you